good evening we'll soon start seeing a
little bit more activity on the las
vegas strip as entertainment options
expand thanks for joining us here
tonight at 11 o'clock i'm denise valdez
now this is all because of loosening
capacity restrictions
oracle mana joining us now live from the
strip with more on what we can expect
orca well denise experts say closures
here on this trip have lost las vegas
tens of billions of dollars over the
past year
but with shows and nightlife starting to
come back
things are looking up but i will come my
hair the night of the show i promise
las vegas comedian carrot top is fine
tuning his funny bone after being closed
for almost one year due to covet 19
his show at the luxor returned this
weekend but with the smaller audience
i'm going to have more jokes than people
updated guidance caps gatherings in
nevada at 100 people or 35 percent
capacity whichever is lower
in any case carrot top can't wait being
on stage is what we feed off of
the energy of the crowd gives you so i
leave with the same kind of high that
the
audience leaves with every night mgm
resorts also announcing brad garrett's
comedy club and thunder down under are
expanding from 50 to 100 seats this week
on the social scene the omnia nightclub
at cesar's palace will reopen in march
but only the outdoor terrace
i think it's about rebuilding analyst
jeremy aguero says with entertainment
and nightlife starting back up the las
vegas economy is turning a corner but
it'll still be a process
it's not going to be uniform it's not
going to be symmetrical certain things
are going to open there may even be some
trial and failure
that takes place but what's critically
important is that things are opening
aguero expects more visitors over the
summer and conventions to return by the
fall
carrot top confident vegas can beat this
virus we're going to tackle it we're
going to do it
now on march 15 capacity for businesses
and activities
for most of them is expected to increase
to 50 percent so the big question
is when will things get back to normal
experts say
that that won't happen for another 12 to
18 months
maybe even longer reporting live on the
las vegas strip tonight orco mana 8 news
now